y
[Música]
kiev anunció la retirada de sus tropas
de la ciudad de leeds ante el que era
hasta ahora el último bastión ucraniano
en la provincia de lugansk rusia aseguró
estar ya en control total de esta región
del donbass
en dinamarca un tiroteo en un centro
comercial de la capital copenhaguen deja
varios muertos y heridos según fuentes
policiales las autoridades anunciaron el
arresto de un hombre danés de 22 años
presuntamente relacionado con los hechos
en eeuu la policía de akrón ohio publicó
los vídeos del asesinato del afro
estadounidense william walker ocurrido
el pasado lunes en las imágenes se ve
como ocho agentes de policía dispararon
decenas de veces contra el hombre el
asesinato desató nuevas protestas contra
el racismo y la violencia policial en
eeuu
buenas tardes bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 soy rosa pérez masdéu y es
para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos con información relacionada
con la guerra en ucrania el ejército de
kiev anunció la retirada de sus tropas
de la ciudad del leeds y chang en la
región de lugansk una retirada que llega
tras el anuncio de moscú de hace unas
horas en que reivindicó tener el control
total de la región de lugansk la ciudad
del isdi chang representaba el último
bastión de las fuerzas ucranianas de
lugansk por lo que las tropas de kiev
intentaron evitar durante días esta
derrota después de haber perdido la
vecina ciudad de severodonezk hace una
semana
[Aplausos]
blandiendo banderas rusas chechenas y
soviéticas se oye a estos combatientes
decir que han entrado en y si sans que
los vídeos fueron publicados en telegram
por ramzán kadyrov el líder de chechenia
y un aliado clave de vladimir putin los
vídeos corroboran las afirmaciones
hechas por rusia el viernes
las fuerzas armadas rusas siguen
avanzando con éxito en la región del isi
tanks en los últimos tres días se ha
establecido el control sobre una planta
de procesamiento de combustible una mina
y una fábrica de gelatina el ejército
ucraniano está sufriendo grandes
pérdidas en esta región
el sábado un portavoz separatista dijo
que el isi suns que estaba completamente
rodeada mientras rusia intensifica sus
ataques contra la ciudad muchos
residentes ya habían hundió
la ciudad ya no existe ha sido
prácticamente borrada de la faz de la
tierra ya no hay ningún centro de
distribución de ayuda humanitaria ha
sido golpeado
y
hubo muchas víctimas yo fui una de ellas
estaba cubierta de escombros la gente me
ayudó a desenterrar me el domingo el
ministro ruso de defensa anunció
finalmente la liberación total de la
región de lugansk tras la toma de
decisións la última gran ciudad que
seguía bajo control ucraniano en la
región su conquista ahora abre las
posibilidades para el ejército ruso a
avanzar hacia asilo bians y crematorios
otras dos grandes ciudades de tumbas que
moscú tiene en el punto de mira armada
y precisamente para abordar la
importancia de la caída de la ciudad del
isdi chang a manos rusas como factor
clave en el desarrollo de la guerra
hablamos previamente con martín
rodríguez osés él es internacionalista y
especialista en temas de rusia el
primero de los objetivos regionales de
esta misión especial que han establecido
los rusos en el que busca el control
total de tanto lugares como de danny
está así que ya estaría cumplida la
primera parte y todo indica que se
tomaría la región de dones en
relativamente poco tiempo para las
expectativas de ucrania y de sus aliados
occidentales la toma de hecho decisión
tomó menos tiempo de lo que se esperaba
porque los rusos estaban tratando de
cruzar un río que se para acceder a
bienes de fichas y les haya tomado su
tiempo pero lo han conseguido y hoy
tiene una concentración de fuerzas muy
grande por lo que es esperable que tomen
el resto de la región en menor tiempo de
lo esperado lo que hay que ver ahora es
si ese avance va a ser este
causado por algún tipo de ataque
ucraniano como se dio y bélgorod que es
territorio ruso
y traten de hacer divergen digamos los
objetivos en el terreno lo cual no logré
continuamos en ucrania porque vadim lee
aquí el alcalde de la ciudad oriental
ucraniana de slogans que reportó el
bombardeo más intenso registrado en la
zona desde el inicio de la guerra según
los medios locales varios ataques con
lanzacohetes dejaron al menos 6 muertos
y cerca de 15 heridos esta ciudad de
mayoría rusófona y conocida como el
corazón industrial de ucrania podría
convertirse en el próximo objetivo de la
ofensiva rusa en el donbass
y más información
relacionada con la guerra en ucrania al
menos tres personas murieron y cuatro
resultaron heridas mientras decenas de
residencias fueron destruidas por
explosiones no reivindicadas en bélgorod
una ciudad rusa ubicada a 40 kilómetros
de la provincia ucraniana de kharkiv
ucrania aseguró que investiga las causas
de las explosiones pero rusia acusa
directamente a kiev laurel tiene los
detalles
la ciudad rusa de bélgorod amaneció con
el sonido de fuertes explosiones que
dañaron a 11 edificios de apartamentos a
39 casas particulares y que destruyó
completamente a una casa según el
gobernador de la región los residentes
atestiguan de la fuerza del impacto
willis el techo se derrumbó y la bola de
fuego no me di cuenta de la bola de
fuego porque ella estaba histérica
levanté a mi hijo y nos arrastramos
justo sobre el cristal así como si
estuviéramos nadando salimos a la calle
yo me estaba levantando en ese momento y
fui lanzado hacia la puerta por la ola
explosiva los cristales de las ventanas
salieron volando mi espalda sufrió un
ligero corte sin residuos estas
explosiones serían producto de los
desechos de tres misiles que según moscú
fueron disparados por ucrania y
derivados por los sistemas de defensa
aérea rusos
quiero enfatizar que este ataque con
misiles fue planeado y llevado a cabo
deliberadamente contra civiles en
ciudades rusas
los activos de defensa aérea rusos
destruyeron en el aire los tres misiles
balísticos que estaban equipados con los
de racimo y fueron lanzados por los
nacionalistas ucranianos contra el
coroto
desde el inicio de la ofensiva de
músculo en ucrania rusia acusado varias
veces a las fuerzas ucranianas de haber
efectuado ataques en territorio ruso
especialmente en esta región de bélgorod
a sólo unos kilómetros de la frontera
con ucrania
y tras la toma de lugar que el ejército
ruso también avanza por el resto de la
región del donbass y por la ciudad de
kharkiv el ministerio de defensa
ucraniano informó que las tropas rusas
presionan en el noreste del país
nuestras enviadas especiales han
comprobado sobre el terreno el aumento
de los ataques con artillería en el
frente de ballack ley a cerca de donets
hasta allí se han trasladado con
voluntarios que llevan comida a las
aldeas del frente es la línea del frente
en el sur de jarquín aquí los ataques
son diarios las aldeas que recorren esta
estepas sobreviven gracias a la ayuda
humanitaria internacional que los
voluntarios consiguen traer cole que
está al cargo del convoy
de las aldeas a las que vamos a llevar
el kit de ayuda humanitaria están
destrozadas y no hay tiendas abiertas no
hay agua ni comida
y van a intentar llegar hasta el límite
con las zonas ocupadas pero para ello es
esencial seguir protocolos de seguridad
en donde se reúnen con las autoridades
locales y emprenden su camino para
llegar a los territorios de primera
línea los voluntarios tienen que parar
en varias ocasiones para cambiar de
vehículos y poder acceder así a las
zonas más peligrosas que están ocupadas
por el ejército ruso pero la artillería
ha disparado contra uno de los destinos
de los voluntarios se ve lezca imposible
llegar hasta allí hay que cambiar de
plan dejarán la ayuda humanitaria en un
lugar seguro a 10 km de los bombardeos
la localización no se puede revelar no
es la primera vez que las tropas rusas
disparan a los camiones de ayuda
humanitaria
los drones rusos vigilan y si ven autos
desconocidos intentan destruirlo si
empiezan a disparar nos si es un local
el que recoge la ayuda y la lleva es más
probable que no le disparen por eso hoy
mañana los voluntarios solo podemos
llegar hasta aquí y dejar los productos
porque el ejército ruso está disparando
cada minuto
hasta este punto llegan también
ucranianos huyendo de las bombas galina
tiene 88 años y ha logrado escapar de
asif primera línea en esta guerra
hubo un misil que pasó por encima de mí
el sonido era ensordecedor y me desperté
en el suelo a cuatro metros de donde
estaba paseando
el chico muy agitado bright es muy duro
vivíamos nueve personas en una casa
pequeña notebook
linkedin adquirió las tropas rusas
avanzan y presionan en su intento de
hacerse con el control de la región del
tomba si kharkiv la emergencia
humanitaria de los vecinos que están
atrapados en el frente y las zonas
ocupadas es extrema
seguimos en europa pero cambiamos de
información con una noticia en
desarrollo sobre lo sucedido este
domingo en dinamarca cuando una persona
ha irrumpido en un centro comercial de
la capital copenhaguen y ha abierto
fuego contra los presentes de momento se
cuentan varios heridos y fallecidos
según las autoridades danesas que han
confirmado tres hospitalizados pero no
han avanzado más cifras eso sí la
policía ya informó del arresto de un
hombre danés de 22 años sospechoso del
tiroteo recordamos esta es una noticia
en desarrollo que continuaremos
ampliando
vamos ahora a eeuu porque este domingo
la policía de akrón ohio publicó los
vídeos del asesinato del
afroestadounidense highland walker
ocurrido el pasado lunes en las imágenes
se ve como ocho agentes de policía
dispararon decenas de veces contra el
hombre que había echado a correr para
escapar de un control de tráfico en el
cuerpo de walker se hallaron hasta 60
heridas de bala la indignación por el
asesinato desató nuevas protestas contra
el racismo y la violencia policial en
eeuu escuchemos la reacción de las
autoridades
no hay duda de que el vídeo que acabamos
de ver es extremadamente inquietante y
despertará muchas emociones y
sentimientos es impactante y difícil de
asimilar
no sabemos el número exacto de veces que
dispararon esto es algo que la oficina
de investigación criminal descubrirá en
su examen de evidencia sin embargo según
el vídeo anticipo que ese número será
alto se disparó muchas veces
colgaron su forma
y cambiamos nuevamente de información
porque el gobierno de israel acusó al
grupo extremista libanés hezbollah de
intentar atacar con drones una
plataforma de gas israelí situada en
aguas reclamadas por ambos países el
episodio amenaza con incrementar las
tensiones sobre la ubicación de esta
plataforma así como los esfuerzos para
acordar una frontera marítima entre
israel y el líbano
estas imágenes publicadas por las
fuerzas de defensa israelíes el sábado
pretenden mostrar el momento en que tres
drones disparados por el grupo libanés
hezbollah fueron derribados dijeron que
los drones se dirigían al campo de gas
de caris a menos de 100 kilómetros de
las costas de israel hezbollah confirmó
el incidente del sábado sin decir que
los drones habían sido interceptados el
sábado por la tarde 3 drones desarmados
fueron lanzados hacia el disputado campo
de caris para realizar misiones de
reconocimiento la misión fue cumplida y
el mensaje fue recibido
líbano a israel que comparten fronteras
se han enfrentado en los últimos años
por los recursos del mar las tensiones
de aumentar el mes pasado cuando un
buque fletado por israel operado por una
empresa griega entró en el campo de
cariz e instaló una plataforma
provocando una rápida respuesta de bola
ya lleva la sabe que él y una niña han
talan
la empresa griega y sus propietarios
deben saber que son socios de la
agresión que se está produciendo en el
líbano en estos momentos
nuestra la instó además a las
autoridades israelíes a esperar a que
las negociaciones que cuentan con la
mediación de eeuu den sus resultados las
negociaciones se han estancado en los
últimos años mientras los dos países que
están oficialmente en guerra se disputan
las lucrativas reservas de energía
y cerramos con la noticia del día en el
continente africano porque los líderes
de áfrica occidental se han reunido en
accra la capital de ghana para revisar
su plan de acción frente a las juntas
militares que han tomado el poder en
malí guinea y burkina faso respecto a
mali los miembros de la comunidad
económica de áfrica occidental
anunciaron el levantamiento de sanciones
después de que las autoridades militares
malienses se comprometieran a celebrar
elecciones legislativas en octubre de
2023 y presidenciales en febrero de 2024
por otro lado los líderes africanos
aceptaron el compromiso de burkina faso
de reestablecer el orden constitucional
en dos años mientras rechazaron el plazo
de tres años de transición democrática
propuesto por la junta de guinea a la
que dieron hasta finales de julio para
ofrecer un nuevo plan
muchísimas gracias por su atención
sigan con nosotros
[Música]